salud en directo américa de france 24 ya
está conmigo en el estudio más romeros a
la mar bienvenida ya feliz jueves hoy es
el día también de la salud y la
seguridad en el trabajo qué cifras
tenemos al respecto mar buenos días raúl
face jueves para ti también
afectivamente hoy 28 de abril se
conmemoraba el día de los trabajadores
heridos y muertos y esto pues ha
derivado la concepción también en un
concepto más amplio de salud en la que
se tienen en cuenta no sólo los
accidentes laborales sino también otros
factores repasemos las últimas cifras
que tenemos son de 2016 en un informe
publicado hace dos años por la
organización mundial de la salud y la
organización internacional del trabajo
1,9 millones de personas perdieron la
vida por causas relacionadas con el
trabajo y la principal causa siguió
siendo la enfermedad pulmonar de
obstrucción pulmonar perdón crónica que
está relacionada por sobre todo con
polución en el aire y dificultades de
respiración le siguen los infartos
también las lesiones 360.000 lesiones
eso es lo que tradicionalmente se
entiende como un accidente laboral y por
último la enfermedad de corazón todo lo
que tiene que ver con las arterias que
no proporcionen suficiente sangre y
oxígeno al corazón entonces dos cosas a
destacar una los perfiles son muy
distintos por ejemplo las lesiones
ocupacionales tienden a afectar mucho a
personas jóvenes en trabajos precarios
manuales y físicos mientras que el resto
suelen ser más graves en los rangos más
altos de edad de gente que acumula años
de malas condiciones laborales y por
último también destacar este 40% que en
realidad son todas enfermedades
cardiovasculares que provoca esta
enfermedad del corazón más
específicamente en este ámbito de
trabajar durante largas jornadas pues
según este último informe que estábamos
nombrando el principal riesgo son las
largas jornadas laborales se consideran
largas jornadas laborales todo lo que
supere 55 horas de trabajo cada semana
no básicamente este problema lo que está
relacionado es con un tercio de las
enfermedades laborales que se
registraron en todo el mundo y también
les cuesta a los trabajadores más de 23
millones de años de vida saludable
perdidos entonces estas jornadas que
provocan no porque está accionado eso
con enfermedades cardiovasculares pues
principalmente por el estrés largas
jornadas de trabajo desencadena
anestesia y pueden pasar dos cosas por
un lado que se produzcan mayores
hormonas del estrés estamos hablando por
ejemplo de adrenalina o cortisol que en
exceso pueden ser dañinas y de regular
el sistema cardiovascular y por otro
pues el estrés influyen factores de
riesgo como el tabaco el alcohol o la
mala alimentación quienes son los que
están afectados por todo este problema
nosotros nos incluimos en todo esto mar
depende de cómo lo estemos hablando en
realidad si por el menos en temas
regionales estamos hablando por ejemplo
si repasamos unos mapas que se
publicaron en este informe de que la
gente principalmente afectada por este
por este problema es en el sudeste
asiático pero eso no quita que en áfrica
y en américa latina' también hayan
problemas de este tipo por ejemplo pues
porque hay mayor trabajo informal
también porque hay mayor precariedad
como siempre los lugares del mundo donde
hay más pobreza también son los lugares
donde se va a exigir trabajar más este
problema se ha ido solucionando o por el
contrario se ha ido agravando con el
tiempo pues podemos decir que ni una
cosa ni la otra ha ido cambiando no
entre 2000 y 2016 vemos que las muertes
han descendido las muertes laborales un
14% pero que las enfermedades las
muertes por enfermedad cardiovascular
han aumentado y lo mismo han hecho todas
esas muertes relacionadas con estas
largas jornadas laborales y además
también alertan que hay un cambio de
tendencia no desde el siglo 20 había ido
bajando esas largas jornadas laborales
de la mano también pues de la lucha
sindical y de los trabajadores por
mejores condiciones en sus puestos de
trabajo y esta tendencia se ha revertido
en los últimos años además el día de
trabajo este primero de mayo marc qué
factores hacen que la situación vuelva a
empeorar pues varias razones que vamos a
apuntar rápidamente que tiene que ver
con nuevas dinámicas de trabajo por
ejemplo la conectividad 24/7 que permite
muchas nuevas tecnologías el teletrabajo
que difumina esas fronteras entre el
trabajo y el tiempo personal y luego
todos esos trabajos basados en trabajo
autónomo y de duración corta como rápido
como ver como deliberó no dinámicas en
las que tienes que trabajar más para ser
en el circuito y que además son trabajos
muy atomizados en los que los
trabajadores no suelen tener oportunidad
de organizarse entre ellos de compartir
también para luchar por mejores
condiciones laborales porque como vemos
mejores condiciones laborales van de la
mano con una mejor salud entonces que
vemos pues son trabajos distintos con
dinámicas distintas pero con la misma
precariedad de siempre que afecta a los
mismos de siempre y como dice smart
también es un trabajo muy individual de
estos repartidores de domicilios gracias
entonces por toda la información mar
pasamos ahora a saludar y a ver nuestra
entrevista que grabamos en la feria
libre internacional de bogotá con
nuestro segundo invitado el día la
invitó que se quede conmigo para que la
vea por supuesto